l'événement sportif hier c'était
évidemment le premier match des bleus en
coupe d'europe l'équipe de france s'est
imposé 1 0 contre l'allemagne 1 but
marqué contre son camp par matt email
une rencontre largement suivi et
commentée depuis les terrasses des cafés
tour n'a pas échappé à la règle
nos reporters samuel colin et paul boyer
qui ont posé leur caméra place jean
jaurès et place plumereau à tours où
l'ambiance et les supporteurs étaient de
la partie de place deux ambiances pour
le premier match des bleus les
supporters sont au rendez-vous place
jean jaurès les serveurs jouent le jeu
drapeaux maillots maquillage c'est le
pays entier qui revit on avait hésité à
le regarder chez nous et puis on s'est
dit que c'était sympa il est beau il
fait chaud en france allemagne premier
match ça se porte la france va gagner à
d'ailleurs comme absorbé par le match à
chaque élection c'est tout le bar qui
tremble pour le plus grand plaisir des
tourangeaux allez les bleus allez karim
pour le patron du bar diffuser cette
rencontre était une évidence les siens
on est on diffuse souvent les matchs de
foot dont quand on a une clientèle assez
assez passionné par le football donc on
essaie de faire nécessaires pour leur
faire plaisir
on savait que ça allait être une grosse
faille et on a eu 100 cents coups de
téléphone cet après-midi et donc on
savait qu'ils allaient être là pour la
deuxième mi-temps direction le vieux
tours maillot de griezmann bape et ou
encore benzema alias bas mono sont
afficher fièrement pour les jeunes
présents sur place ce match d'ouverture
permet enfin de se retrouver après de
longs mois de restrictions ça me fait
tellement plaisir d'être là avec mes
potes pour l'ouverture du match et pour
les bars et pour la réouverture tout
simplement c'est mieux d'être un
extérieur au bar
ventre monde franchement c on revit
enfin on ressent la plupart des bars ont
dû refuser des dizaines de réservation
les serveurs cours de tables en tables
sous une chaleur écrasante
hier j'ai commencé à en refuser en
réservation et l'art au passage
énormément jeudi au fusil 30 personnes
car personne moi c'est physique et puis
la chaleur
fatigue énormément mais c'est une bonne
ambiance que s'aggrave à 22h30 plus
aucune commande n'est possible les
serveurs commence à ranger les terrasses
au coup de sifflet final les bleus
gagnent et les français explose de joie
prochain match samedi 19 juin à budapest
contre la hongrie d'ici là la flamme du
football n'est pas prête de s'éteindre